man look at this drip tonight yeah i'm
not comfortable at all whatever i'm not
because you're usually showing off dim
guns
i'm just yeah
it's like it makes a weird sound but
it's awesome it's prada
i can't talk bad about it no you cannot
can not talk bad about it but i can't
talk bad about your golf game no you
can't dude my 20th time playing man well
honey you almost took out an innocent
bystander oh no first off i told him to
move i said you better move yeah your
four was like four four
i'm not a loud speaker you know hey at
least you were hitting that ball cause
poor jaylen wrote i was trying to say i
wasn't even the worst person on my team
jalen yeah not calling out any names or
anything jaylen rose
all right tonight we are calling out
names because this man right here is
making history right here at the vmas
the first male country artist taking the
stage and performing at the vmas have
you wrapped your head around that how
you feeling about your history-making
moment i feel good you know i'm kind of
upset that i'm not singing a country
song but uh you know i'm also it's kind
of good because people would be like oh
this is a country artist why is he
singing this song man hopefully they go
down a rabbit hole and they discover a
lot more artists in the country bro yeah
without a doubt grand it is awesome it
is catchy but honey it is poppy oh yeah
will there ever come a time when you
feel like you might transition entirely
into the pop genre versus the country i
know you love country music because he
even sings that in his latest song
no no no
no i mean i got a 17 song album coming
out there's only like two pop songs on
there maybe two and a half to one my
wife it's kind of poppy yeah but uh no
i'll never just transition straight to
pogba hallelujah because music city we
love you kane brown we're gonna love you
on that stage anybody that you're hoping
to rub elders with tonight say hey
no
uh but i mean this is where all my
collaborations have happened as like not
country shows
so we'll see oh so who are you collabing
with next before you leave me i got to
see this let me see
i heard you had a really nice watch on
okay it's really nice yeah with all
sorts of bling
yeah i would this is this is uh
i'm from fort oglethorpe georgia
and i like i don't even want you to look
don't even look at it
i'm not paying for it it's not mine i'm
so scared to even be wearing it that new
album is different man's gonna be paying
for it so is that tour get out of it no
it's going straight back
[Music]
you